in my family that was a serious business
if you ever came late to breakfast there
was a really good chance you weren't
going to have one hi i'm cesar and today
we're making my family zarebas i was
born in caracas venezuela when i was six
we left venezuela for the united states
arepas are a type of bread that
venezuelans eat we eat it for breakfast
lunch and dinner one important thing you
want to remember is that the cornmeal
has to be poured slowly to the water to
eliminate any chance of having clumps at
the end of the stirring you want to make
sure you have a very dense dough ball
you know the arepa dough is ready when
you press your fingers against it and it
doesn't stick to them the story behind
my parents is they met in college my
father was from venezuela and my mother
was from bristol virginia he was on a
scholarship and he had an opportunity to
come here and learn but caveat to that
was that he was going to have to return
to venezuela and spend some time working
there which meant after my mom and he
fell in love she was going to have to
come with him she had a lot of struggles
and culture shock when she was in
venezuela but one of the things that she
really could confide in was learning how
to make traditional venezuelan dishes
with my grandmother so the great thing
about arepas is you can really have them
with anything but my favorite way that
it's prepared is my mother's chicken
avocado recipe it's something that we
call reina pepiada it consists of
avocado cilantro salt and pepper and
chicken you can use pulled chicken but
if you don't have time to make that you
can also use rotisserie style arepas
were always a big part of our breakfast
we used to have them with scrambled eggs
ham and cheese and butter one of the
things that i'm really proud about for
having two parents from different
cultures is the perspective i have on
the world i get to appreciate so many
things because i've seen it from so many
different angles i'm really thankful to
my parents for keeping up with our
traditions from our native land now i'm
here at tasty studios making my own
videos so i really feel like it's the
torch being passed down oh yes
you